les soirs d'hiver
chanter
pourchassés
le djia qui rôde
c'est par oddo
[Musique]
quel duo quand même félix le faire mon
et clairac et quelle voix monique décédé
hier à l'âge de 91 ans sa carrière est
absolument exceptionnel comme interprète
comme actrice ou si comme comédienne ça
s'est échelonnée sur plus pop à foix
près de 70 ans et son ami le compositeur
françois dompierre qui a signé sa
biographie pas vraiment parce qu'il soit
qu'il y en ait une ya signé le roman
l'irak le rendement d'une vie bonsoir
françois dompierre
je pense qu'il faut commencer par vous
offrir à vous et à toute votre famille
de musiciens et de ce monde de la
chanson des condoléances parce que vous
hirvo juste un mois et fait normal
qu'ils en compagnie principalement des
pianistes je pense à johnny da rocha les
gens marchent à plein monde de qui on
fire de rigueur y ont bien oui mais
quelle chance vous avez eu un jour
malgré tout de la rencontrer dans une
épicerie et que de là raconté moussa et
de la ce faire rendez-vous qui donne ce
roman la sédition c'est que monique vive
aviv ville à certaines comme moi mais je
savais pas vraiment et puis un jour j'ai
chaud à l'épicerie et puis avec mon bon
montpetit qui monte kadid je frappe une
dame âgée mais bien portante et vous
pouvez pas faire attention
excusez moi madame au françois
j'ai failli être désagréable monique
c'était monique mans et puis et là je
les invitais à venir manger à la maison
elle disparaît je suis en quelques mois
plus tard il est venu et on a fait une
longue soirée au terme de laquelle je me
suis pas dans laquelle elle m'a dit
qu'elle ne fait ne chantait plus depuis
25 ans mais autant de laquelle monsieur
installé au piano puis j'ai commencé
pour cet amour qui vient au monde et
elle s'est levé à telle qu'en elle-même
s'est mis à chanter pour cet amour
bientôt en sus les mauvais démons et
directement d'une vie vous dit que c'est
la plus grande voix elle personne la
plus grande voix du québec pour une
raison simple pas parce que c'est la
plus grande voix du québec mais parce
qu'elle a doublé cette voie là de d'une
facilité pour la mettre en scène cette
voie là c'est la fête
elle a fait du théâtre avec sa voix
d'abord c'était une actrice dans un
premier temps et pour elle chantait
c'était un moyen de doubler son métier
d'actrice et c'est ça qui était
chanteuse quand on parcourt les lis très
rapidement et on a le goût de lâcheté de
l'offrir en cadeau de suite on voit tous
les gens les plus grands qu'elle a
côtoyés dans sa vie et on découvre
l'homme de sa vie aussi eu une relation
brève mais mouvementée celle de jacques
normandie
mais charles aux normes qui aurait été
l'homme de ce réveillon sans jamais
parce que quand cette dernière j'ai des
doutes un peu là-dessus même source une
autre surprise mais elle a côtoyé rasch
et hasna vous oui oui elle était témoin
du début de la carrière de d'amour et de
pierre roche bien sûr mais surtout celle
désavoue pas ce qu'est l'amour est
devenu célèbre
et puis elle l'a même aidé parce que
c'était un apatride d'une certaine façon
à cela vous revenez ici chanter elle l'a
menée aux états unis
et puis elle était donc témoin de ce
fait ils ont chanté à la même époque
dans les mêmes salles
est-ce que vous parlez oui dans les
mêmes temps ils font même ils vont vers
québec un moment donné ils sont au
faisan doré 120 kw qui vont
on sait déjà qu'elle a côtoyé les plus
grands
elle a même demandé une surprise elle
chante et c'est piaf qui vient la voir
oui oui piaf qui lui a dit qu'il y
aurait reçu comme ça de temps en temps
la visite de très grands ou de grands
interprètes notamment celle de piaf qui
lui a dit madame cette expérience que
vous faites et puis voilà vous devriez
faire ceci et puis monnet qui a dit oui
merci madame est en fait qu'à sa tête
comme à l'habitude
et puis a eu la visite que si plus tard
de barbra streisand à new york c'est
d'ailleurs parce qu'un champagne et qui
venu lui dire à quel point mes
chaussettes encore plus peut-être plus
impressionnant parce que ce qui est
extraordinaire avec layrac
c'est que c'était une comédienne chante
c'est d'abord ce on n'avait jamais vu ça
une personne qui pouvait jouer du racine
qui peut jouer bérénice de corneille
prouvé qu'il pouvait faire 2-2 qui
pouvait faire tous molière et qu'il
avait fait avec le tnm c'est une des
fondatrices du tnm elle a joué du temps
des frères gascon de jean louis roux et
mario land allemand ou est un mariage
ans d'alma qui était qui était aussi son
professeur d'une certaine façon est ce
qu elle a eu la carrière qu'elle qu'elle
voulait oui quelles réponses qu'elle ait
reconnu la carrière qu'on aurait
souhaité que des revues la garder pour
on aurait voulu qu'elle fasse ces partis
consob de cd audio avant le terme parce
que elle aurait pu faire se chercher un
post-it mais elle ne voulait pas
pourquoi parce qu'elle voulait faire ce
qu'il a fait c'était fait beaucoup de
ces fleurs dans sa retenue et à mener
quand vous lui demandez de ce2 chante à
nouveau à dia c'est un fantasme oublies
ton fantasme françois oui exactement
quand je ne chante plus je veux que les
gens se souviennent d'une bonne
chanteuse mais non pas d'une vieille
chanteuse
maintenant c'est terminé j'ai fait j'ai
fait j'ai fait la paix là dessus puis
elle est vraiment fait l'appel oui oui
tout à fait passer thoune peut se
permettre des décisions et qui n'y
revenez pas avec jacques avec justement
avec jandal mais aussi
avec monique quand c'est terminé c'est
terminé est ce que ce n'est pas une
femme n'est ce pas facile le nom des
regrets je n'ai pas senti ça elle a dû
avoir des regrets parce que je les sens
quelquefois sur bord des larmes quand on
a discuté de la biographie
ce n'était pas simple à faire la
biographie parce que je lui ai eu des
passages je voulais pas nécessairement
que ce soit une biographie autorisée
mais en même temps voulait bien qu'elle
soit plus d'accord parmi ses nombreuses
prestations prestigieux il ya est sûre
le vin aussi oui pas donné à l'époque
et puis elle le faisait de façon tout à
fait naturelle
certes les douces et le candidat
concerné douce et belle voilà vous le
must la voix je ne sais pas je sais que
ça a commencé par la comédie oui
commencé par faire commises mais sa
voile avait naturellement c'est ce qu'on
appelle une naturelle naturelle dans
tous les sens étaient
et son amour parce que leur gagner avec
des chansons de vigneault à ce poste
notamment à sopot à s'opposer à ostende
oui son amour des leclerc vigneault
n'est liga oui c'était important de
mettre un poète en scène ça c'était
important d'ailleurs elle a inventé un
genre de spectacle qui préfigure un peu
ceux de robert lepage dans un sens parce
que et elle est seule en scène
interprétant des textes de poètes de son
pays et en les joints littéralement
mettant en exergue chaque mot de ses
poèmes accompagnés par la musique c'est
pour ça qu'on en perd jamais une parole
si vous remarquez quand on écoute des
chansons
quelle que soit la vitesse est fabuleux
et elle vient de la vie du très mauvaise
oui elle venait d'un milieu absolument
modestes y avait que son frère qui avait
été qui avait au collège classique et
qui avait un peu de culture etc son
exemple qu'il l'a porté mais ensuite de
sahel et s'est fait présenter les axes
soit elle-même dans le lied les
commandes on le dit que c'est grâce à
elle c'est elle qui l'a
interprétant pagny site à l'origine elle
est à l'origine de sa 4l a appelé après
la chanson gagnante l'abandon dans ma
camaro oui alors qui est une chanson
faite un peu par hasard comme souvent
les rites des tessons fait oui
simplement dont c était prête et puis
bon voilà il a fait cette chanson là
parce qu'à d'aidé lui a dit andré gagnon
lui a dit vous fasse quelque chose de
plus simple à jouer tout de même
pourquoi faut pour me proposer que je
participe à laquelle il faut de la
camaro gagne on est justement écrit ça
donc ils ont fait cette chanson là qui
est devenu un grand succès et que
monique beaucoup puni parce que oui elle
était de ce milieu là aussi elle aimait
la chanson populaire puis m'ont indiqué
admin modèles pour faire pouët charmante
a dit pourquoi tu m'en fais pas alors
vous écrivez à la fin mon éclairage qui
est en quelque sorte un morceau notre
patrimoine la voix poignante d'un peuple
pour cinéma celle du but on n'a pas fini
d'évaluer la portée historique de son
apport son influence auprès des
québécois entre les années 60 et 90
jours laisse le mot de la fin
c'est absolument c'était son action
politique
monique n'a jamais fait de politique
directement mais le fait d'avoir chanté
ce qu'on était partout au monde et
surtout au canada anglais parce qu'elle
est allée pas au yukon partout à la
colombie britannique à terre neuve elle
fait tout le tour et surtout ça c'était
son l'action politique alors on lui rend
hommage on lui dit un grand merci moi
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs
j'étais avec un deux dix jours j'ai
changé j'ai joué un peu de piano à la
maison c'était assez émouvant parce que
elle savait qu'elle partait oui je crois
que oui allez grimpe des larmes comme ça
moi jamais de l'air de quoi
non ça je jouais du piano qui avait déjà
dû de la résidence qui était là c'était
assez c'est assez beau ouais je dis au
revoir monnaies puisque tout est parti
je lui dis bonjour merci beaucoup de
d'avoir partagé votre monique par ce
roman d'une vie quelques minutes avec
nous ce soir mais on vous dit un grand
merci france soir merci beaucoup à vous